so do you agree with solzhenitsyn about
the
what is it uh
the line between good and evil runs
through the heart of every man yeah that
all of us are capable great line yeah
evil
i i read
a good chunk of the gulag archipelago
when i was a teenager
because my my grandfather had it in his
house because he was one of these
americans who was obsessed with the
soviet union and the soviet threat
and and wanted
people to to be aware of some of what
what had happened um and so
so he had those books lying around and
and uh you know i would i would read
them and it's a similar
kind of parallel story to the
to what happened in in in germany during
the war you know this creation of this
system of camps and and
oppression and and uh lots of um
troubling behavior
to me it's a story of um
how fear and desperation
combined with a charismatic leader can
lead to uh to evil but it's also a story
of
of bravery of of love of brother
brotherhood and sisterhood and and
basically survival you have like a man
search for meaning which is the stories
of uh the story of a man
in a concentration camp
basically finding beauty in life even
under
uh most extreme conditions so to me
world war ii is not necessarily
um a bleak view of human nature
it's it's it's a little
moment of evil that revealed a much
bigger
good
in humanity so i'm not i'm not so sure
that it leads me to a pessimistic view
of the world the fact that uh somebody
like hitler could happen the fact that
uh
a lot of people could follow hitler and
get excited and maybe even
love the hate of the other yeah for some
moment of time
i think that's
all of us are capable of that but i
think all of us also have a capacity for
good
and i think i don't know what you what
you think but i think we
have a greater desire for good
than evil and that it seems like that's
where technology is very useful as a
guide
okay it's a helping hand okay okay can
you give me an example maybe
so i give you examples of futuristic
technologies and i can give you examples
of current technologies current
technologies
uh knowledge
uh in the form of very basic knowledge
which is like wikipedia
and
search the original dream of google yeah
that i think is very much a success
which is
making the world's information
accessible at your fingertips
that kind of
technology
enables the natural
if if this
axiom this assumption that people want
to do good is is true yeah then
letting them discover all of the
information out there false information
and true information all of it
and let them explore that's going to
lead to a better world to better people
futuristic technologies is uh i
personally
i mentioned to you offline sort of love
artificial intelligence
and so
ai that's an assistant that's a guide
like a mentor to you yeah that you can
in the way that this google search is
but smarter where you can help send it
out and say
this is the direction in which i want to
grow not
uh authoritarian lecturing down from the
algorithm of telling you this is what
this is how you should grow but almost
uh the the opposite where you use it as
um
an assistant a a servant in your journey
towards knowledge yeah that that sounds
like an easy thing but it's actually
from an absolutely very difficult
you